it's over it's almost over
it's nearly over tonight tonight tonight
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka spoiling king
and god finally came down to save us
from the first finale of the stand
in case you don't know this is pretty
much the climax of the book
but stephen king himself has created a
brand new ending for the series which
will be airing next week
we're going to be breaking it all down
but if this is your first time here then
please subscribe to the channel as you
don't want to miss our
very very enthusiastic thoughts on it
and also
yeah click the thumbs up if you've been
enjoying the breakdowns now this episode
arguably feels like it has some of the
highest
and lowest points of the entire season
making for quite a weird entry we pick
up in the aftermath of last week's
reveal
with the group of survivors being held
captive in a jail in las vegas
i kind of feel like this situation had a
lot of similarities to ice
but that's me probably just drawing
conclusions over what the political
messages behind the show could be
glenn very much belabors the point that
there clearly exists a lot of fear
amongst the citizens of the city
as randall flagg has to rule over them
with an iron grip
though flag states that he gives them
freedom we know that people who
question or defy him are severely
punished and thus
they aren't really free flag is very
much a populist who promises to allow
people to live the way that they want to
but only so long as he deems it to be
fit
he also has slaves which the city is
built upon but this is completely
downplayed
it feels like it might be a comment on
western society
but due to the fast of the proceedings
the subtext doesn't really come across
in any substantial or meaningful way
now i do feel like this is the message
that glenn tries to put across during
the following court hearing
which though meant to be overly dramatic
is a bit weak and farcical he drops some
nice lines such as flag being the mother
of dragons
however i think it's the performance by
lloyd that really lets this scene down
in the source material lloyd is a highly
accomplished killer at this point
who shows little humanity or remorse for
his actions
he was a complete psychopath whereas
here he seems like a quivering bell boy
who puts on a good show but ultimately
is completely powerless
now with what the show is set up i do
think that this arc works slightly
better for him
especially because he was introduced as
someone whose reputation was built
completely on a lie
throughout the episode he clearly
struggles with flag's actions
and in the end becomes one of the key
voices that brings him down
it does deviate highly from the source
material but
if this is the route that they're going
then overall his arc does make sense
however one character that i feel gets
short-changed is glenn
who doesn't fully get the final scene
that he deserves
though his death is probably the most
impactful one in the series
he and flag actually come face to face
in the book and have a conversation
flag promises to let him go if he begs
for mercy but glenn instead goes
off on his rant and calls him a roach
this renders him powerless
and thus he has to get lloyd to shoot
him in the work his dying words are it's
all right mr henry
you don't know any better and though
this final act of defiance is brought
across here
it could have been so much more however
at this moment does make the crowd see
lloyd for what he is
and it robs flag of his powers though no
one other than him knows about it
now another big difference in the work
is that nadine is still alive in the
show at this point
and she arrives to see larry who shows
her her true face
i think that it becomes clear now that
flag had hypnotized her into believing
that she was still beautiful
but upon his powers being stripped away
she's able to see just how ugly she's
become
they do alter quite a lot of things in
her death most notably that she actually
goads flag into killing her
after their encounter in the desert
nadine was almost in a complete state of
catatonia
and she snapped out of it just in time
to talk flag who tossed her out of the
penthouse
on the way down he could see her smiling
and he realized that he'd been tricked
whereas
in this entry she has a lot more agency
and chooses to do it herself
aiden smashes the stone into the window
and jumps out
not only carrying this idea of
shattering a symbol of flag
but also making a public display of
defiance against him
however one of the big problems about
the show is that i feel that
this entire storyline is heavily
compressed
king's original work was an epic and
here a lot of the character nuances are
crammed down to tell a story in these
eight episodes
meaning that a lot of the orcs feel
slightly rushed
nadine goes from completely worshipping
the man to hating him in the next scene
and though we have seen some duality to
her throughout the season
it felt like it was slightly unearned
obviously i am familiar with the source
material so
i am able to follow this story quite
well so i'd actually like to hear
if you haven't read it can can you
follow these moments or are they just
getting lost on you
let me know below now out in the wild we
see stew who unlike harold
doesn't take his own life randall's wolf
arrives to attack him
but glenn's dog called jack fights him
off meaning that the character can be
found by tom cullen later down the line
stew goes on a bit of a weird one and he
better hope that nuclear fallout doesn't
exist in this world
otherwise the lads gonna be in trouble
after the death of nadine
lloyd wears his michael jackson thriller
jacket as a tribute to the character
and we can see the cracks start to form
a great moment that can't show because
of youtube monetization
has nadine's head served on a platter to
larry but instead of seeing it as
something to taunt him
he actually uses it as a power play
nadine being offered up like this
clearly shows that flag is the monster
everyone suspects he is
and though i didn't really enjoy the
first half of the episode
the latter half really steps it up a
gear and feels like the kind of tone and
scale that we should have got in vegas
personally i would have just combined
the court scene with this one in the
hotel
and had glenn argue the flag on the
balcony but i guess having this many
extras on screen at once and renting out
an entire hotel is costly
catherine mcnamara does a great job of
riling up the crowd i think
as does mahomy alexander skarsgard who
really shines his flag in his final
monologue discussing how abigail's ways
in itself
are a disease that they must stamp out
larry realizes that flag doesn't know
she's dead already
which means that his ability to see has
slipped away and thus he recites an
element of psalm 23 whilst being beaten
which makes others rise up against flag
stripping him completely of his power
when the almighty arrives
now by the almighty i of course mean
ezra miller
who has delivered an emmy-worthy
performance this entire season
he's brought a lot of subtlety to what
could have been a farcical role
and has probably given us one of the
best performances
ever caught on camera by that i mean the
trash can man completely under delivers
and it sucks that we never got an arc
for him at all
he's pretty much just a deus ex machina
that pops up with a bomb so that god can
come in through the hole that nadine
left
and strike down flag's followers before
detonating it
he doesn't really have anything to do
other than that and it just
feels like a complete waste in my
opinion i do like though that his skin
was completely melted off by the
radiation
but yeah such a strange performance in a
show
that played things straight for the most
part i even kind of got the idea that
trash can might have been working for
god the entire time
due to him saying the bomb was for you
whilst looking at the sky
but as we didn't follow him enough it's
completely impossible to tell
anyway god descends on them like the
ending of riders of lost ark
and completely tears up shop lloyd gets
final destination
and the others are torn apart by
lightning now an important thing to know
is that larry and rey do die
however they don't die afraid the latter
was worried that would happen
and is somewhat a satisfactory way for
the pair to close out
they die on their knees in a prayer
formation as the bomb goes off
completely decimating vegas a flag
does disappear before things go off and
he will likely return next week in some
form or another
on the outskirts of the town tom finds
stu amongst the ashes
and though they probably would have been
dead within minutes due to the bomb
it looks like everything is going to be
m-o-o-n and that spells a-okay
however they might tackle the fallout of
this in the final episode as
obviously there'd be a lot of radiation
in the air
but you know we don't know where the
shot at this point it could be
very very sincere in one minute and then
ezra miller the next
now back in boulder franny and joe see
the explosion light of the night sky
and the latter says that he's gone
frannie starts asking if the boy can see
stew
and then goes into labor which ends the
episode
now as a whole i did think that this got
things back on track slightly towards
the end
but the finale it really could go either
way
king has said that he's had it in his
head for about 40 years
so i hope it delivers but as far as
bringing the book to screen
i did feel that this ending lacked in
some ways
i actually think that they've left
enough out of the book that they'll be
able to fit it into next week and keep
things pretty much the same
but there are rumors of a time jump so
we'll just have to seek
obviously let me know your thoughts on
the episode and what you think will
happen next week in the comments below
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 28th of february
in which we're giving away three copies
of the marvel phase 3 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message
me on twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of last week
which will be linked on screen right now
we're also doing weekly coverage on one
division which i'm enjoying a lot more
so yeah give that a watch as well
without the way thanks for sitting
through the video
i've been paul and i see you next week
take care peace